Microphone's on, shirt choice is instantly regretted, time to make a video.
*Intro*
Hi, my name is Grace Helbig. If you did not know, now you know. Your life is different now!
(whispers) Oh god, if my neighbours go on their porch they can definitely see everything I'm doing, so here's hoping!
They have other activities to do on a Friday night. I'm in my kitche-
I got distracted by moisture.
I'm back in my kitchen, because today we're going to do math... Just kidding,
I'm gonna make food, which is a form of math. It's adding things to things to make a different thing. Wow, cooking is math.
Why don't they just teach cooking in high school and get rid of math? Just like combine the two, and then kids won't know that
they're actually learning math because they're learning cooking. I'm a genius...
I was in the grocery store the other day, and I saw these. These are Egg Roll/Spring Roll Wrappers
And I have never made homemade egg rolls or spring rolls, but I didn't want to make normal egg rolls or spring rolls,
I wanted to make them really trashy, real just straight up garbage rolls, because
who I think I am on the inside is just...
...An actual can of garbage. I thought what else can I put inside of an egg roll/spring roll that isn't
traditionally an egg roll or spring roll? Macaroni and cheese.
I'm going to stuff some egg rolls and spring rolls with macaroni and cheese and create what I'm calling
a 'Mac Ah Geez Roll', 'cause it might be so delicious
you're going to get angry at it
You can be like 'ah cheese', so let's do it! First thing what we have to do is make our macaroni and cheese
This is very self-explanatory. If you don't know how to do this by now, you weren't raised correctly.
I'm not looking at the instructions on the box, YOU'RE looking at the instructions on the box. You're a box, you're an instruction, you...
...Suck a [dick]. Just kidding, I enjoy you.
Where's our liquid measuring cup? You get really angry when I don't use my liquid measuring cup
and I use my dry ingredient measuring cup- Agh
Yes, okay, six cups! Should've got a bigger measuring cup
What amazing content(!) Aren't you glad you're here? Have you subscribed yet?
Is this six? Yes, of course it is.
Okay, I think I'll boil this water so (haha!) definitely should've done this beforehand.
Okay, we're gonna boil this water and as much as I know that's the content you want to see on this platform
I'll spare you.
what did you diddle yourself [hold] [on] that kind of obnoxious fizzling noise is
Veggie dogs been making Coco Veggie dogs because you'll find out later don't worry our water is trying to boiling
and I'm very impatient so now we're going to our noodles to the water cool accent have a
Good job you guys look tiny and then we cook them seven to eight minutes or until they're done
I don't [know] why I'm [just] verbatim telling you the directions that are on every box of macaroni and cheese if you can't read for
Whatever reason here is how to make macaroni and cheese? I'm not judging you
I'm just thinking of any negative things about you, but not out loud. Just silently in my head totally it's different, okay
we're going to let that boil seven eight minutes cook these veggie dogs and then
Okay, okay
Okay
According [to] the man our noodles are done cooking that means we're going to drain them and then put them back in the pot add
To them make them real pretty give them a makeover like every 90 teen
Rom-Com type of movie the water is the glasses [as] soon as we take the water away and add a couple little accessories
It's like holy. She's a beautiful the whole time. Oh
My ribs are very supple cool good job four tablespoons of Margarine or butter
I can't believe it's not butter at four tablespoons
That's an excessive amount who am I to judge and putting it inside an egg roll, and I'm deep-frying it
I mean yay, two three four Fl. Oh
Gosh 1/4 cup [of] milk. I'm very lactose
Insist to make this macaroni and cheese, and she's um pretty dumb
Hey party
And then the cheese mixture which is this mysterious white packet that if you saw this in any other?
Location other than your kitchen straight from [the] box you probably report it to the government
Let's put it in the thing that we're going to put inside our body
I don't put all the cheese mixture just like a lot than that
This seems very soupy
Which is not necessarily consistency you want um your macaroni and cheese  to be is it possible that I have fucked up?
possibly easiest and to cook on the planet
Yeah, okay [wants] to cool down a little bit anyway be able to put it in our egg roll
so I'm going to put it in the
refrigerator for a little bit that sounds crazy, but
There's no other part of that sentence
commercial [bar] Mac and cheese has been in the refrigerator for like [ten] minutes and it sort of looks like Mac and cheese now I
Have another camera set up over here
So you'll be able to see my sleight of hand when it comes to making these egg rolls
so the egg rolls say that they need to be
Deep-fried in at least two inches of oil so I have that going in the Saucepan here
I don't know you're diddling or whatever I?
Chopped up my veggie dogs so that I can add them to some of the egg rolls and see if that makes any
delicious delightful
Flavor difference
I also learned that you need a beaten egg to use as glue to roll up your egg rolls
Which makes sense  egg rolls, but I don't have any egg so I'm going to use water mother nature's egg
No, mother nature's egg is an egg. Do what happen?
I have my [oil] already heating up, so it gets to a boiling temperature
Which is I don't know I take one egg roll wrapper. It place. It like a diamond shape [for] our body
oh third cup of fillings
[I] don't know what that means, but I'm going to put about that much in [and] I should put it back this way, okay
[so] this gets rolled over and yes, I'm doing that yeah
And then you roll it like that just an elongated roll
And then this is [where] [you] I guess you take your beaten egg
And you use it to I don't know to go to the edges so [that] [they] fold in
Maybe and then you do these edges. I don't know I've abandoned the directions
[I] spiced the reading got difficult [and] you roll it all the way up that looks
Maybe like an egg roll still looks a little bit like an egg roll
Let's make a couple more actually before we test our oil that would be some of our chopped
Veggies dog in there, I don't need I can inform [word] [church] that coconut oil for three to four minutes [here] we go
oh
There's no sizzle, but a completely anti climatic moment for all of us okay this [one]. What's that another them?
Another [anti-climatic] moment da Fuck guy. I mean they're boiling here you guys look at it
Like shits happening put the other ones in ready except these have the [meats] [in] them. I mean the fake meats is
Okay, [ah] one more oh my God snug [as] bugs in a rug
Also, I never understood that phrase why who bugs in a rug is not snug to me. That's get the fuck out uh my house, okay?
Let's see how these go. Oh my God. They're boiling. Okay. This must be in number three to four minutes. This is so exciting
Let's maybe turn them over. I don't touch them. No. I don't like you guys
You [just] have to have to handle you  guys are looking like egg Rolls [oh] my god. Oh my God, okay, okay, okay?
I don't want to do I'm going to take them out of the boiling oil
I'm going to let them drain off on a paper towel for a second meet you right back here for the final product
go, I mean
Triple diddle okay. Oh my God tada you see this can you guys see this? Oh my god oh my God?
Oh my God these are our mac oh geez
Roll and you're so [lunges] macaroni and cheese. [I] put some sriracha on the side. I didn't know what condiments
what was it and that felt like a
Ketchup ish, sure. Maybe we can use mustard I don't ha ha
Move on it's so good. It's so good and so high tastes like an egg roll with Mac and cheese inside
Which is essentially what we were going for it almost exactly what we're going for
If not exactly what we were [going] for a seat?
I think the bigger ones have to [think] meat in it
well, you're going to have to you about a it's all for my love of
content creation
[hah] can't [say] shit. It's too hot
Thank God is it delicious because that might be the last time [that] I taste anything?
So I think it just burned up all of my taste buds. [oh], holy. Sh. This is really good, okay?
Well, that's the end of the video. Thank you for watching [I] hope that you guys try making Mac cheese rolls
They're actually way easier
Than you might think [if] you liked this video give it a thumbs out [amid] [all] your favorite foods in the comments down below
[so] I can figure out ways to
Come up. Don't forget to subscribe to this YouTube [channel]. I make videos Monday Wednesday and Friday [sometime] other than that
I don't know this video [is] a real educational experience
I've learned that
this is not the most flattering shirt that I own and there's a good reason that it's been hanging in my closet [for]
Almost a year. I'm glad least one of us got an education out of this video